hi everyone welcome to this session my
name isasa Marvin I'm very happy to have
all of you join us today and uh today
I'll be taking you through a session
called caras 3 for the curious and for
the creative and I'm going to divide
this session into two one is car us for
the Curious then take you through its
parts and then another session call Car
us for the creative it's going to be a
two-part
Series so on the car three for the
Curious first of all I'm going to take
you through what caras is and then take
you through the latest development in
caras uh we've been having caras but
today we have a new version of caras
called caras 3 we move from caras to
caras Co and even to caras 3 but as we
go into caras of course the different uh
verticals that you can you can
challenges that you can solve with Caris
you can solve computer vision problems
with Caris or even natural language
problems with car or even other problems
as well and as I take you through car 3
for the curious and creative I'm going
to focus more on computer
vision that means that first of all I'm
going to give you a computer vision
refresher and even just show you that
images are just numbers and then from
that
point also excuse me I have some I'm
under the weather in case you hear me
cough over and over again but uh we'll
still be able to manage the session
so I'm also going to take you through
the different de planning Concepts and
show you how these different de planning
Concepts translate to caras and even
translate to tensor flow and the
difference between caras and tensor flow
and how the two works together and then
we could see a quick quick object
detection with caras cor and Jax
together with with other other tutorials
around K around K 3
so we used to have something called
kasas cor it's it's the version of K
that we had before the K three so we had
caras and then we had some updates on
kasas and then today we have kasas 3 and
the updates on kasas was K score but K
score has been changed into K three so
in case you see K cor just just know
that it's K three in in that particular
Point okay so uh the first thing we're
going to do is probably just introduce
you to what the planning is and to do
this I'm just is going to give you
probably um a short a short a short
exercise here if you see my screen you
can see that we have values of X and
also values of Y and on the X you can
see that we have number one number two
number three number four number five six
seven on the X side x is just a variable
and then in this inside this variable we
have this
list and of course you can print the X
but then also we have a y variable and
then this y variable also has some
values here and if you check on them
probably you may in some way find the
relationship between X and Y if you see
it keenly you can see that this number
is seven and if you check the second one
you can see the number is moving to 14
then moving to 21 then 28 then 35 then
42 then
49 and then if you check on it maybe at
some point you may be able to see that
there is a relationship between X and Y
to a point where if you have maybe eight
here you may be able to find what the
value for y is at this particular point
and um if you probably go deeper into it
you may you may find out that the the
relationship between X and Y is just 7x
meaning that you've been able to check
the values of X and the value of y
figured how figured out how they
correlate to each other and at the end
of it you have a number seven or a
gradient seven that defines for you the
relationship between X and Y and um if
you check on this IDE what you're trying
to do is you're trying to approximate y
as a function of X and in some way
probably this what the planning is
because in the planning they're saying
that we have things called neuron and
even for propagation and uh in some way
you would say the planning is just
Matrix manipulation because what you're
trying to do is just you're always
trying to approximate why as a fun of
X of course with some weights and
bies and if you check on this number
here you can see that these are a simple
linear equation that could Define the
two relationship that that we had shown
you on the other side and this linear
equation you could see that it has some
computation part of it it has
multiplication here addition here I mean
it has some processing that it does
meaning that today if you bring some
input here as a as as X for example
and then do some processing with the
input you'll end up with a with an
output called Y and probably this Al the
same way that this works is almost also
the way our brain works where you have
you have axone dries nuclear cell body
you have a neuron a single neuron here
on the left and this
neuron it's able to take inputs it's
able to take inputs from maybe your eye
or somewhere else then do processing
with the in put and then at the end of
it give you an output and from from this
neuron here we've been able to have
things called neuron Network we've been
borrowed we've been able to borrow the
idea of neuron networks from from these
neurons because it also Al also almost
be like a linear
unit and when you when you train your
data of course
um you're always trying to you're always
trying to approximate y as a function of
X but the way it works with the planning
is that the first thing you'll do is
that you'll make a Gaz work you'll make
a Gaz work of what the gradient is you
may say okay maybe I think the gradient
is is maybe nine of course here you add
you add the value seven uh but in the
planning the first thing it will do is
it will try to make a Gaz on that value
and then once it makes a Gaz
work it will figure out how it will it
will figure out the results with that
value of x that you have what what
answer will I get then the answer that
it gets it will figure out how the
answer is far from the True Value in
other words you figure out how to get
the error in the in what You' predicted
from the ground truth so you have a
predicted value and the ground truth
then you figure out what's the
difference between the two and if you do
that you'll be doing something called
you'll be calculating the loss and
therefore uh at this particular part you
may you may have been smart to the point
where you're able to go ahead and get
the value of the gradient almost
immediately and say okay I think the
gradient is seven but with the planning
you're going to make a gwor come up with
a number plug it in get an answer then
figure out how that answer is far from
the correct True
Value and then once you do that you're
going to once you make the prediction
which is also called a forward
propagation that entire process you're
going to calculate the loss and say that
okay this is my loss and of course the
different ways in which can you can
calculate the loss you can decide to get
the absolute value the mean the absolute
value of some answers then then get the
mean mean of it you can do something
called mean absolute error or do mean
square error I mean that different ways
to get to get to get that error that
you're
doing and your goal is going to be to
figure out how to minimize this error
that you're
having so at this particular point you
may decide to maybe have have a curve or
figure out how the error is sensitive to
the weights what is it that you can do
to the weights to Ure that the error
reduces um
and you may decide to plot a curve a cve
like this on here where on one side you
have the L represented as J of w and
then you also have the weights then if
you draw this curve then it will look
like this one here and uh you you can
assume that at this particular Point
probably you have like the maximum error
and then your goal is going to figure
out how can I get the best sets of
Weights that's going to give me the RIS
loss and that's going to be your work
your work is going to be how do you now
optimize how do you optimize the
predictions that you're making how do
you Ure that the predictions that you're
making are as close as possible to the
ground truth so again you make a
prediction calculate the loss and
then calculate the gradient of the loss
with respect to to the parameters the we
can say c as a function of output and
truth and then you're going to you're
going
to figure out how to go in the to go in
the direction of the of the of the to go
in the negative Direction and then
iterate this process over and over again
until you get the best sets of Weights
that gives you the least
loss and um you can think of probably
reducing this loss as probably someone
who is let's say on top of a mountain
and all you want to do is to find let's
say Mount erest and your goal is going
to be to figure out how to go down the
hill all the way to the lake lake or all
the way to the valley so for example
suppose you're at the top of the
mountain and your goal is to reach the
lake and then let's say you're blind
blindfolded and you need to figure out
how to move from one point to another
until you go down the lake so
[Music]
um that's probably a way in which you
can go down the hill and reduce the
weights that you're having and just to
summarize all these ones what you're
going to do with de planning is that
first of all you're going to have a
forward
propagation uh which ideally is the
process of passing your input data
through a neural network to produce for
you an output of course you're going to
start with an input layer and then move
forward layer by layer until you reach
an output layer and at each layer the
input is multiplied by a set of and then
pass through an activation function and
I'll show you what an activation
function is in the next slides don't
worry about it but that's what we have
on the F
propagation and then once you have this
F propagation you need to figure out
what's the error and how do I go
backwards to ensure that I'm able to
update my weights uh or change my
weights in a way that reduces the loss
that I'm having so this entire process
called backward propagation and this
ideally is the process of of updating
the weights of the Neal network with a
goal of minimizing the error
between your predictions and the ground
truth or the desired
output and it usually starts at the
output layer and then move backwards of
course move backwards layer by layer
until it reaches the input
layer and at each layer the gradient of
the error function is calculated and
used to update these weights so this
entire process you have the forward
propagation you have the backward
propagation and then you're using the
all together to train your neural
network and the for the forward pass is
used to calculate the output of the
network while the backward pass is used
to update the weight of the network to
reduce that error that you're having so
the process the process is repeated over
and over and over again until you're
able to increase your accuracy or
produce an accurate
prediction for every input that you you
give to
it so probably I could show you maybe um
let me check if I have something on the
code okay maybe I could show you a few
things um here and
there
okay let me share my entire screen I
hope you'll be able to see the entire
screen say share because I want to share
with you a
collab
okay I'm just sharing my screen in case
you're wondering what's happening in I
feel you should be able to see my
screen okay I'm I'm I'm trying to I'm in
the process of sharing
it uh yeah I believe you can be able to
see
it okay so I have a bunch of slides here
I hope you can see it
now okay so this this is what I've been
talking about
um the neurons the linear units and how
the linear units relates to the neurons
and
um this is the equation I talked about
where you have the values of X and the
values of y and you're trying to try
your goal is probably to figure
out the relationship between X and Y and
you can in fact write a code that helps
you to figure out the Rel relationship
between X and Y of course you can do
this normally maybe with n and other
other other python code but you can also
use this amazing tool called caras which
I'll tell you more about it don't worry
about it at this particular moment to uh
translate this image here or the
equation that we had the image you're
seeing here I believe I hope you can be
able to let me increase the
size a little bit and then do
that yeah that's
better so these the X values and these
are the Y values and then you can
translate all this into caras I'll
should tell you what caras is
um but it's it's it's it's it's a nice
API or a python API that allows you to
be able to Define uh deep learning
models or rather allow you to
the we yal
WX and you could think that linear unit
something called a layer because a layer
is um you could think of a layer as an
object an object that encapsulate
something called a state and that state
has the weight and then also it also has
a processing ability and that processing
ability is just doing the the
multiplication uh and the addition or
just doing the numerical computation of
all this so anything that can that that
has a state and then that also has a
processing
capability then that's something that we
can call a linear a linear we can call a
layer so at this particular point you
could see that um we are importing caras
and I've told you that caras is a high
level API that allow us to build to
easily build the planning models or to
easily Define our layers Define our
models um and and ideally just remove
the cognitive load of working with other
other tools that could probably make us
write a a large chunk of code so that's
why going to have caras here to help us
translate what we've talked about the
theory we talked about into a practical
example so caras also has
modules and inside those modules we have
classes uh different classes for example
you here you have a sequential class
from this particular module in the Kass
do models module and then also you have
um you also have these other classes
that also that are all layers as well
and they from the car layers so a model
is ideally a graph of layers remember a
layer is an object that encapsulate a
state and also has a also has a forward
propagation or or or also has the
ability to do uh the numerical
computations
so we have this sequential layer here
and also we have this one here these
other layers here as well so I'm going
to convert all this into n n array you
can see I have them there and then I'm
going to Define define my my model so
here I'm using sequential of course the
different ways in which you can create a
car model and um one one way is to use
something called sequential sequential
API another way is to use something
called functional API
and another way is to do model
subclassing so there are different ways
in which you can create a car model but
this is usually the simplest way to use
a sequential model and sequential model
is where I just
pass a list of layers inside this
sequential model so here we Define a
variable called model and then we
instantiate this class this class of
ours for sequential and then inside it
we're going to pass a list of the layer
that we have so you can see here we have
like one input of that shape we just
defining what we're having here this one
here and then once we Define it we
can now probably compile our model and
compiling our model it basically means
that we are freezing our settings we are
freezing our settings and trying to make
it ready for all the computation that we
need trying to make it ready for doing
the for propagation
trying to make it ready to do to
calculate the loss of course we're going
to make a Gaz work initially then once
we make the Gaz work we're going to
figure out the loss so we going to free
settings for the loss and there
different ways in which you can do
calculate the loss there's a mean
absolute error there's a mean square
error and a bunch of them and of course
once you make that loss once you figured
out how your prediction or the first
prediction or the guess that you made is
far from the ground
truth and you have this that call a loss
or an error you're going to find ways in
which you reduce the loss and toce this
loss is is doing something called
optimization so we're going to do
something called optimization here and
there also different ways which you can
do
optimization you saw how we were
descending from the hill all the way to
the to the lake and of course to descend
that way we able to first of all
calculate some gradients and you can say
we are descending the gradients or we
doing something a gradient descend and
that descent may be random or maybe
chaotic and you can say okay probably
the way I'm descending the hill or the
mountain is uh something called
stochastic so one way of
optimizing
all the optimizing the model that you're
trying to build is by using stochastic
grent but of course the others as well
you have things like Adam RMS prop a
bunch of them that you can use and all
these you can get them from the k.
optimizers if you just go on the
documentation you'll see the bunch of
them that you can use of course not all
solutions will have
SGD or not all solutions will also have
Adam and also this this
um optimizers there's something also
called um the the learning rate and that
learning rate ideally it means the steps
the number of steps that you'll take as
you go down the of course I'll show you
I'll show you more of this on the slides
but now I just want to show you like
what you're having here and then once
you've once you've optimized your
network you just need to figure
out when I make a prediction how many of
my predictions are going to be correct
if if I'm making predictions of 10
numbers out of this 10 how many of them
are going to be correct so you need to
have a a way to check the number of uh
predictions that you're making correctly
or a way to evaluate the model that
you're having have a matrix here called
accuracy that will help me to check how
good or that will help me to check the
quality of my
model and then at this particular point
I'm going to now approximate y as a
function of X over 500
aox then once I do that um you can see I
can be able to see the loss that I'm
getting I can also be able to see the
accuracy that I'm
having and after all those aox you can
see that now I can be able to probably
have a model then I can probably try to
make a prediction maybe of the number 10
cu now I already have a model I already
have a
model and I have some accur somewhere
and you can see that um it thinks that
probably the prediction of 10 is is 69
and
uh this this is almost close to 70
because you know that if you
multiply if you multiply 7 by 10 you'll
get uh you get you'll get 70 so that's
just a simple way to probably DOD
planning okay so since we have this um
let me go back to my my
slides um and this is where I was taking
you I just wanted to show you that I
could probably get an image from my
desktop I took this photo of myself with
my phone and then I could load it to
collab I'm just using collab here let
me put like this so that you guys can
see it very well so I can load this
image to my folders here just just do
the normal upload and then from that
point I can be able to use uh I can be
able to use the P the m m plot Library M
plot Li library to plot uh the image or
just to display the
image and then first of all I believe
you guys can hear me let me just let me
double check that that you guys can hear
me okay okay perfect okay all
right let me then go back quickly I know
we out of
time all right perfect then once I have
this image I can be able to probably
check just double check the size of the
image that I'm having of course I also
have this image on on my desktop and I
know the size of it I know it's 1 to8 1
to 80 to 80 pixels then you can see
that's the exact thing I have here and
then um and my goal is to probably
convert this image in
into into pixels because I told you that
there are two types of photos you can
have a gray scale image and also a
colored image and for gray scale image
you'll be having an image that's that's
R that's having the different shades of
gray or that's ranging from maybe a
light part of it to a part that's dark
on the gray scale image and then for the
colored image you'll be having three com
a combination of three colors that's the
red the green and the blue and and the
combination of all these colors can
always give you different typ of
different types of other
colors and in this particular image you
SE that we have one80 by 1280
pixels um here 12080 pixels and I want
all of you to think about pixels as just
dots on the image so with this one here
for example you have 1280 dots by 1280
dots on this particular image so every
particular Point you're going to have
dots and dots and dots and dots and dots
with pixels and every single Pixel
represents a number that's ranging from
0 to 255 depending on how dark or light
the particular area is and an area
that's white like this one we we
probably expect we expect a number
that's close to to 55 and an area that's
probably dark like this one we expect a
number that's close to close to zero
maybe 20 maybe 30 or even maybe 40 or
something so here we expect a number
that's close to zero a place that's dark
and a place that light like this one we
expect a number that's close to
55 in other words we have dots on the
photo these dots are what we calling the
pixels and every single dot represent a
number that's ranging from 0 to
255 and then I'll be able to um so my
goal is to convert all to convert the
pixels in this photo into a matrix of
numbers and uh of course I have a slide
where I want I want to show you the same
but what I want to do is that I want to
I don't want to put to0 by to0 rows and
columns on my slide so the first I want
to do I want to resize this photo into
probably 6x6 so that I'm able to easily
draw a 6x6 kind of uh thing on my on my
on my on my slides so the first thing
I'm doing I want to do here is to resize
the photo um you can see here I'm
resizing it from one 12880 to
6x6 on the rows and columns then I can
display what size this is now what I'll
have from the original 12801 1280 image
so this is how the photo would look like
if I resize it and
then um from this point now I can I can
probably
get the get get the rows and
columns with the Matrix with the Matrix
of numbers or rather get the value that
I have at every at every pixel point in
my photo so you could see that the
partes that are white I have a number
closer to 55 and the parts that are dark
I have a number that's heading toward
zero and I can even convert all this
again into a matrix of numbers so that
at the end of it I can convert my image
into a 6X into a 6x6 Matrix of numbers
and in fact this is how a
computer understand images it understand
images in the form of um in the form of
Matrix of numbers so this how a computer
will understand my
images and then of course I also know
that um today probably some of you
have are using Instagram some of you are
using SnapChat or some of you just using
cameras to to use something called
filters on on your photos so you'll do a
filter on the photo but sometimes what
usually happens when you do a filter is
that you may just be having another
Matrix of numbers that you're trying to
multiply with the matx of numbers of
your photo so I know the different kind
of filters that if you multiply with the
original photo here you'll be able to
you'll be able to have a different kind
of photo at the end of it so for example
here I have a range of filters here one
of them is called appliation filter and
this is how it looks like so I can
define a appliation filter here and then
I can decide to multiply or apply the
filter on my image and uh if you apply a
filter on an image probably you can
start centering it at one particular
point and then do do a bitwise
multiplication you can be doing
something convolution so if you do
convolution with a photo you can be able
to have maybe a different type of photo
if if for example I have this photo here
1 to 80 by 1 to 80 and then I rescale it
to 6 by six because this is what I want
to plot on I want to have on my on my
slides and then if I apply that La
filter to it these the results that I'm
having but I know this probably may not
make a lot of sense to the guys are just
getting started with what computer
vision is uh or the guys want to be
curious to see how does it really happen
my photo so probably I need to show you
what happens if I take that s appliation
filter and instead of convoluting it or
instead of multiplying it with the
rescaled 6x6 image I could multiply it
by the original to 180 by to 180 image
so if I go down
here you could see that I could apply uh
I could Define a range of filter I could
Define a gaussian blur to blur my photos
I could Define an edge detection meaning
that I could decide to probably remove I
mean highlight just the edges in my
photos or iight do something that help
me detect detect the edges from my photo
or brighten my image so if I do the same
thing if I take those different filters
you can see how the array looks like for
these different filters and the range of
them so if I take those filters and
apply them to my photo um these are
these are the things that will happen I
have the original photo here uh 1280 by
1280 you can see 1280 by 1280 and then
if I apply the gaan BL this how it looks
like I can apply the Ed detection
meaning that I got remove every single
thing and just remain with the edges of
my photo this is what I'll be I'll be
able to have and then I can also go
ahead and apply different FS to my photo
and in some way what I'm trying to do is
that I'm trying to I'm trying to
identify some unique things in my photo
I'm trying to highlight some unique
things in my photo just by using a
filter and uh in some way probably what
I'm trying to do I'm trying to maybe do
feature extraction I'm trying to I'm
trying to extract some unique features
from my photo by having the original the
original image and converting that
original image into Matrix of numbers
and then having a second Matrix a second
Matrix that
has that I can be able to Center
probably somewhere on my photo
particularly in a place I want to
extract some features from the photo and
then I can run it all over my photo uh
probably with some strides I can define
a stride on how I run it from left to
right um all the way to the bottom and
then once I run it in some way I'll be
able to extract some features from my
photo okay so enough of this maybe let
me get back to my
slides okay I hope you
showing all
right okay so again as you've seen im
images are just numbers an image is just
a matrix of numbers and uh you can see
here on
uh pter you can see on the on the left I
have the same photo that I was showing
you of course this photo is 1280 by 1280
in size but then I can be able to
convert this photo I can rescale it into
6x6 uh size of the image and then show
convert all this into into a matrix of
numbers and even display it in a table
so this how how you could um probably
have the the pixels
value so that take us into something
again that's called Data data
representation there's a way that you
can be able to represent different types
of data of course you have structured
data and then you also have unstructured
data structured data is the data that
you have in in a table you have the rows
and the columns but unstructured data is
the dat that uh probably are like images
I like videos I like audio so the
different Reon in which you can repr
this data and then of course you'll be
using things like linear algebra to to
try to understand to represent these
images so um in some way again the
planning is is just Matrix manipulation
or matrix multiplication you've seen how
we've
multiplied uh the matrixes of our image
by the values of of some weight
somewhere or the values of another
filter somewhere so've been able to
multiply let's say some X and and some W
somewhere and um all we always trying to
do with this planning is just to find a
find a way in which
um y relates to relates to relates to
the images or the x value or try to
present y as a function of X you can
take the values of filters the weights
and of course now you know you know that
you can have W as let's say the filters
X are the Matrix of the matx of numbers
and then you may also have you may be
seeing some b b's here so this B could
just be a bias and this bias could
probably help us to reduce over fitting
in our model um just allow you to maybe
just shift the model to reduce over
fitting and then also you could be able
to probably see some some some character
here and probably wondering what this
one is because you've been able to see
what x is as the Matrix of the Matrix in
our photo and the weights there which
you could take the filters as the
weights and bias is just to help us
reduce overfitting it could just be in
the Y intercept but now we also have
this other this other character there so
this character you could you could um
think of it as something that will help
us to reduce non linearity or or if you
just have the original equation you may
just have you may just model maybe a
simple linear equation but the kind of
data that you're going to have is all
the kind of distribution you're going to
have may be very complex and you may
need your equation or your model to be
able to to be able to define or rather
model this complex distribution and
therefore you need to have some
activation functions or some you need to
add some nonlinearity to to what you're
doing or to your layer so that you're
able to model this complex this complex
uh operations so at least um we've been
able to understand every single thing
here uh you know what x is you know what
the weights are or the gradients are you
know what the bias is and even what this
value
is and um of course I've also explained
to you that
um this different this different values
of of of Sigma or nonlinearity just help
you to learn the complex relationship of
all these ones okay um and then also
probably the other one the one that you
may not have seen is the Y value so
probably I could tell you why what Y is
this just a simple equation of what I've
shown you um so y could be the labels or
the preds we want to make and you could
say okay probably if you're doing image
classification you may have this data
set that that that K has or flow has
it's called the fashion amness data set
and this that data set you may have U
you have different types of of of
clothing you have dress you have shoes
you have you have different different
types different types of them and um
this one could be our labels that we
having on our photo so once you have
them maybe you can probably decide to
convert all this into let's say a list
and say okay now I have a label you can
define a variable here called label and
then put all those things in a list like
this one here but these on are still
numbers um so is there a way in which
you can you can handle these categorical
variables is there a way which you can
convert all these one into a way that
now you can be able to have everything
in a number format and there there
thereby approximate y as a function of X
so yes you can be able to do something
called one hot
encoding where what you do is that in
every part
where you have you have a true value of
something let's say a shoe you make that
part hot if address is there you make it
hot if something is available that
particular point you make it hot the
same way you have it here and therefore
one hot encoding I what you're trying to
do is that each row represent a sample
and each column corresponds to one of
the one of the classes that you're
having then in each row all the
values set to zero except the column
that correspond to the class from which
this image is taken so that particular
column you make it hot when uh when that
thing is
available Okay so so yeah and
then maybe we can now move to something
called a neur a neural
network um
and let me just move here I've talked
about neuron neurons I've talked about
layers and you know that um layer a
layer is
basically a linear unit that is able to
receive an input do some processing and
then give an output um or you could say
it's probably I Define it if you are
maybe a coder you could say Okay a lay
is maybe an object that in capsulate a
state that state has uh the weights that
state has um just the weights that
you're having weights weight and basses
for example and then it also has the
ability to do to do computation all the
F propagation that you're having so
that's a layer and then you can have um
different models that can give you um
different layers like this one that you
can see on the screen you can have input
layer hidden layer and a bunch of other
layers and if you can group all the
these layers together you could say it's
um it's it's a deep neural deep neural
network so probably could we could try
to see how all this concept converts
into into maybe a model so um for
example here you could see that
you you you're importing tensor FL from
TF tensor FL t t you're putting ter of
flf and then you're creating a function
here that can return for you a model and
in this function you're doing a
sequential model at this particular
Point um this this is one way of
creating a car model from the tensor
flow but today you can even decide to
just create CS outside tensor flow
without necessarily using tensor flow
you can decide to use any back end of
your choice you can say okay maybe I
want to use a jack back end or I want to
use a py toch back end or I want to use
any other back ends that I want to use
but this one is uses a tensor flow back
end so here you define a model and there
different ways in which you can create
also a AAS model can use sequential
functional and all that so here we're
using the simple one the sequential way
where we just pass a list of layers to
the sequential
layer and um of course you can see here
we have a convolution layer we've talked
about convolution already you've seen
what I was having on my on my cab you
could see how I'm having the original
images then I'm
having uh some filters then these
filters move on the image to do some
convolution operation so here is the
convolution operation and then also you
may want to
reduce you may want to reduce the size
of the image or the dimensionality of
what you're having but pass the most
important features in that particular
photo to the next layers so you can do
something called Max pulling of course
the are different kind of pulling you
can use there's the average pulling
global average a bunch of other you can
do but Max ping usually works well
because it it highlights or takes the
most important feature from let's say a
particular a particular block and then
transmit it to the next layers and then
you can you can now Define the PO size
maybe 2 by
two and then the St here we have the
filter and it can also Define an
activation function here you have re
there also a bunch of other activation
functions that you can be able to use
for for this particular model so yeah
um these are some of the key gr
ingredients for deep planning uh You'
seen that we we've been able to probably
represent our images using things like
linear algebra we' been able to um
probably have layers we doing
computation layers and models we've
talked about activation functions we
talked about the cost or the loss talk
about optimization and you can see that
um in the background there's a lot of
mathematics happening happening in the
background there's linear algeb
there's probability there's calculus and
all those ones there's some heavy mats
or some mats that's going on under them
but um I know probably you very good
with maths but if you have this at scale
um even if it was getting like a simple
gradient but now you need to do
gradients for for millions and millions
of parameters it may be very hard for
you to do that and therefore probably
you need a tool that could help you to
automate all these ones can do for you
automatic uh let's say
differentiation can do for
you can ideally make your work easier
when you're doing with this one and
therefore this probably a way in which
you can be able to um EAS in your work
and and and that's where now car and
tens flow or caras and and backends come
in for you and by backend I mean tensor
flow I mean caras I mean pouch and I
mean tensor flow Jacks and even py and
and those ones
so um in some way or or rather the
mission statement of carers is is is to
give something called an an unfair
advantage to any developer who want to
ship machine learning powered apps uh
into the market and what this means is
that or the idea is that you don't need
to create your entire machine learning
architecture from scratch because car
will give you this this these simple
reusable small cool elements that you
can actually use inside of caras so you
have this apis that will help you do the
complex stuff that you do but even if
you do this complex stuff still it will
allow you to even do give you the
ability to do to manage the complex
stuff so it allow you to start simple
but even start simple it doesn't deny
you the chance to do the complex things
so K just provides you a high level API
for building this de planning models and
uh the F of K Fran is saying that
probably caras you can think of car as
the python of De planning because it's a
user friendly de planning language that
offers a variety of workflows for users
with different profiles be it a beginner
be
it an expert be be someone in the
intermediate level or or even someone
who is doing research so K us give you
this different workflows that you can
use and probably you're wondering okay
now you're talking about car but where
does it tensor flow comes in uh how
where is tensor flow how does it come in
yeah um the funny thing is K was
released way earlier than even not way
earlier but was released earlier than T
of FL in fact
car was released eight months before
before T FL because K was released in
March of
25 was released in March of 2015 while
tensor flow was released in the November
of
but aside from that just you can think
of tensor flow as a low level a low
level tens a low
level let's say Computing platform while
car is a high level de planning
API but what happens the background is
that um T flow will give you will give
you an infrastructure that you can use
to do the tens M multip multi
manipulations or an infrastructure that
can help you to do the automatic
differentiation and then on top of it it
can also give you GPU acceleration but
you may also want to think about
tensorflow as not just a tensorflow
manipulation infrastructure or not just
an API but you may want to think about
it
as as an entire platform it's an entire
platform um where other people also able
to build their models add to it you have
developers using it uh this is beyond
the the automatic differentiation beyond
the tensor manipulation beyond the GPU
acceleration so it's an entire platform
and not and not just an API that that
you're trying to
use so and on the other side caras will
give you inbuilt optimizers loss
function um while tensor flow give you
autograd engines for automatic
differenciation so um car optimiz L
functions are simply high level
obstruction that make it easier to use a
tensor flow automatic engine so that's
that's
how that that's how that's how um all
these both k and t flow uh work together
but it's very important to keep in mind
that tens flow is much more than just a
library much more than just an API much
more than just a t manipulation
infrastructure it's a platform uh where
we have an ecos system of components
being developed by googlers and some are
even being developed by by Third
parties and uh if you check on the on on
the on the key building block of caras
another way to think about car is to is
to probably imagine that you're trying
to build a house and say
okay I want to build a house but when
I'm building this house K gives me this
building blocks that I'm trying to use
and K is going to give you the building
blocks that
are kind of uh simple and consistent uh
for example if you you need a door you
need a door that you don't want to use K
will give you something called Data
loader um K will will will give you
things that you can be able to to use in
different ways so you just need to use
the loader and then and then use
it okay but you have things like uh the
inputs data pipeline construction
compilation training inferencing of
course you've seen some of on the on the
on the
code so of course to use car the first
thing you need to do is to import import
the necessary packages we need to import
the packages you can import tensor flow
today you can even import pyo you can
import
Jacks then you can import
car and then um the next is going to be
the data
loader every single thing that needs to
pass through the door that that you're
going to
that you that that the Leger door that
you're having then once you get this
thing you're going to shuffle them
rearrange them randomize them and and
prevent the model from from learning the
way in which these things come in ore
prevent the model from going to overfeed
when you're going to train
it and then in some way you're going to
pack them nicely pack them neatly into
different groups uh you can call this
batching uh and da batching improves the
efficiency of of the training model and
then you may also decide to do some
specific operations through things like
map function etc etc before you before
you get the data in so there's a data
pipeline element of
it and then you're going to do model
construction um in model construction
there are different ways in which you
can create AAS AAS model one way is by
using the sequential object or the
sequential API and the sequential object
you can think of it as a container of
the neural network you can think of it
as a foundation of uh of what of the
house you're trying to build all the ler
block you're trying to build a
foundation in which you're going to add
layers on top of each other in a
particular way if it's a sequential
model then in a sequential manner on top
of each other and then you could add the
braks then you could think about things
like activation function to be let's say
the glue or motor that holds the two
bricks
together so um again you can think about
caras or the sequential object
as a foundation and then on top of this
Foundation you're going to have bricks
bricks that you're going to lay on top
of each other and these bricks are just
the layers that you're using and this
bricks in between them you can have an
activation function and this activation
function you
could think of them as a glue or a
motor so here just another code again
just to to talk about the same thing
we've been talking about can show you
how to transfer to transfer maybe an
architecture into into a model that
you're
having activation function the number of
units the sequential you're having these
going just a list you're passing ins the
sequential object that you have uh then
at the end of it you're going
to you're going to freeze all the
settings and prepare um your model to
meet the data that you're going to have
um so this is just the compilation and
the things you specify is there the loss
how to get the loss using things like me
absolute ER the mean squared error
Etc and then also you're going to figure
out you're going to also indicate how
you're going to reduce that error or how
you going to optimize the model that
you're having and the different
optimization techniques that you can use
including RMS prop including Adam
including SGD you SD on my code and then
now you're going to Define what metrix
you want to use so yeah I mean just
that's how you could quickly create a a
k model
but you've seen that uh the two key
things here all the two key things when
you're building a model is
um the first one
is caras then the second one is is uh is
tensor flow so caras allow you to Define
your layers and all that while tensor
flow allow you to do automatic
differentiation but um is T FL the only
automatic differentiation do we have
others what if we have a common
interface to leverage all of them so um
with tensor flow you have things like
gradient tape that you can use with
things like py you have torch.
gradient with new tools like JX or new
or other automatic devors like J Jax you
have jx. gradient or J.G grad and
um the key question is what if we have
like a common interface to leverage all
of them and today we have something
called K call or K 3 and K 3 is um is
IDE a full right of
K that support different buckin meaning
that today you can
write you can write um you can have a UI
with car but change the buck the way you
don't want to change them you can say
okay probably I feel Jack runs faster I
need I need I need I need a faster weit
to do the calculations maybe I want to
use Jax and then use Jax as the back end
you just Define Jack to the back end
I'll show you it on the code I'll say
that probably I feel maybe I need to use
tensor flow on the back end say okay
maybe I want to use P Touch in the back
end so you can use all the ones as
automatic differentiators you can even
use NP but the difference between n with
the three is that Jack tensor flow and P
can do automatic differentiation while
NPI can't do automatic differentiation
and that means that the only thing you
can do with NPI as a back end is just
inferencing only and today you don't
have to do tf.
caras um you you could just use from
caras import all the that if you were
using other backends and of course this
works seamlessly with the key verticals
in D planning including K NP and even K
computer vision or k
CV so here's like a simple code on how
you can do it um of course this is K
score but I'm going to show you in the
code on my code uh how how to use K 3
with it you can see here I'm still
having just simple layers input layer
dance D are hidden layers and then an
output
layer where I need to pass the number of
classes and maybe an activation function
and then can check my model summary and
then I can freeze all the settings and
get the my model ready for for for my
data then I fit the data and then maybe
do the evaluation to check on it and
then that even do prod soltions but the
key thing here is that I could switch my
back ends the way I want I could run
tens flow on the back end or run P to on
the back end even run jacks on on the
back
end and of course you know that
um on this K also has things like K CV
that you can use that also works
seamlessly with with all these ones so
and K CV offers arrange of things from
layers dentation metrix model loses
bonding box and utilities um I think one
of my favorite one is data visualization
because it makes it easy to be able to
visualize the data and like how you you
may probably how you'd use let's say my
li for
example
then the EXA EXA thing that it has is
the image generation which are also show
you in a
few today K C has an implementation
something called stable defici don't
worry about that ter deficient I I'll
discuss what it is in the next slides um
and of course it has this on top of
image classification object detection
and that documentation so it has all
these ones that we have use of things
like backbones that you can use these
IDE are models that are
reusable already been trained so can you
use them for different purposes
of course um you can if if you're doing
something called transfer learning where
you have a PR model and you want to use
it for other
purposes apart from the original
purposes that it was it was said to be
used maybe you want to extract features
from from from your data or you want to
use you want to not just extract
features alone but also do something
called fine tuning of this models so you
can do both feature extraction fine
tuning of the models use of dat
argumentation uh this could easily help
you to reduce overfitting if you
training an model U things like cut mix
random argument rescaling resizing
random
share and data visualization also
provides you with a range of things like
all the ones
here and yeah there's some Sage um you
can see how it looks like um use of
object detection you can see here it's
supports it has full support for YOLO
V8 and etc etc segmentation there as
well um yeah so maybe I could uh
probably or let me finish all the slides
then I'll take you to the code don't
know how long I have here
42 I think maybe I have some 20 more
minutes okay so that that one is that
one I'll take you through has three on
the slides I want once I move to the SL
I don't have to once I move to the col I
don't have to come back to the slides to
prevent the
delays okay all right so um that one is
on the side for the caras for the
curious I did just taking you through
what's latest in caras or rather what
what what what caras is what FL is
what's possible with caras what's the
planning um giving your computer vision
one refresher and then give the latest
things in K such as K
3 okay then on the creative part I want
to introduce you to something
called table defici and how cars allow
you to be able to do to be able to do
things with generative Ai and just do
things generative AI alone but even how
you could do multif framework generative
Ai and by multif framework generative AI
I mean that you can generate
images using car classes on different
bucks you can do that on jcks you can do
that on tensor Flor you can do that on
um on even on even
P so I'm I'm doing this session
from from nirobi Kenya and uh there
these two images that I've been using a
lot in in Kenya where one of them is is
generated while the other is a is a is a
true image so um of course it's it's not
probably it's easy to know that this one
is generated at least from my P sessions
and this one is is a true image and this
an image from BBC on how people fish
fishing on Lake Victoria like Victoria
is in East
Africa in Kenya Uganda Tanzania
countries in East
Africa and this is an image generated
maybe a fisherman like
Victoria so
in in some of the tasks that we've been
seeing for computer vision we've been
seeing that you can have an input image
then this input image you extract
features from
it of course do feature extraction using
the
convolutions uh using using convolutions
including filters and Max
pulling and the Matrix and the Matrix
from the on The Matrix numbers from the
image once you've done that then you'll
be able to do some tasks um
you'll be able to do some ta some task
on top of it you can do tasks like
object detection you can do tasks like
um classification you can do tasks like
segmentation some of them that we've
seen above but this one this one for
example casing point you can see that
you can put an image or give a model an
image and then the will tell you that
the image you're
seeing it's of a mango will give you
output like an
mango but what if you can switch this
entire thing to a point where instead of
showing a model an image what you
do is that you show an
image a word like a mango or give it a
text for example or a text
prompt for example a fish man like
Victoria or an ason ring a I think this
this has become very very common in
almost every single thing but um
of course this photo was generated by
it's called Del del d 2 and it was one
of the first mainstream text to image
models which was very nice but if you
check on it you real
that it originally it wasn't open so so
it was very hard or very few people were
using it at that particular point
but then came something called
stability something called stable defici
or uh from stability AI um that's 100%
open source and you can do text to image
models um and you can write like a
prompt like this one let's say a Fisher
man Victoria Kenya with a T-shirt and
then give it like the kind of photo you
want is it clear Focus coherent
whatever then from that point you can be
able to like have an image like this
here on on the
right and the way it works is that
there's this concept called super
resolution and that super resolution
is a concept that um says that if you if
you train a de planning
model that it's it's actually possible
to a planning model to do something
called denoising of an image and when
you Denise an image then you can you may
be able to end up with a higher
resolution
image so you can have an image for
example on the left and then if you do
Den noising on that
image um you can have a model that can
run on top of the image and then make
that low resolution image to become a
high resolution image and this thing is
called super
resolution and um there's a way that the
super super resolution model kind of
recover the information that you're
having
and of course it doesn't do this this by
Magic
um it it uses something called a
training data
distribution and that train dat
distribution what it does that it
hallucinates
is is a big thing let's say
on generative AI so it it kind of uses
the training data distribution to
hallucinate the visual details that will
be most likely given the
input and you can push super super
resolution to the limit so push super
resolution to the limit to a point
where instead of running a model on top
of a noisy image you may just decide to
R to
run a Model A de planning model on Just
Pure Noise instead of just having an
image somewhere then the the model will
noise the image then on its own start to
hallucinate a brand new image and it
could repeat this process over and over
again uh to a point where you can turn a
small patch of noise
into a more clearer and clearer high
resolution um artificial picture and um
this are almost house but also how sa
defici works and uh sa defici is I mean
this a key Concept in something called
defici and St defici is ideally a text
to image generative model um it uses
text descriptions to generate
images um or do image toage translation
but but you'll get it with with
prompts and of course um one key Concept
in this table defion is something called
lent space walking which basically means
you're going to sample a point uh in a
latent space or kind of way and then
incremented change those space
representations so for example if you
have for example if you have an image
like this one then you could add noise
to it you can have a clear image add
noise to it then add it
again and this we call for for defion
where you can have a sample image and
then through through a series of steps
that I calling my co chain steps or let
me just say through a series of steps
you can be able to add noise at each
each of those steps then at the end of
it you'll have a new a new a new
variable then you can also move from
noise to a new image
where you just have an image with noise
and then if you I mean through a series
of teps you can be able to come up with
a new with a new image this called a
reverse process or a reverse
Def and um ideally the defion process
involves taking an input image then add
noise to it over series of
TS and thenur network is going to train
to recover the image by rever by
reversing the noise or in another way
you could say that
probably you're going to um I mean and
and this way you're going to have like
an image at the end of it but what if
you can also add another process called
conditioning and conditioning here is
where you ensure that probably you don't
just end up with any any kind of any
kind of
image probably you have a text prompt
somewhere and this text prompt you
project it into a l Vector space or have
a vector representation of the text and
then you concatenate it to a noise patch
of course this is going to be done um is
going to be done for you on the on the
back end so don't worry about it don't
worry about it this just an explanation
of what's happening so you're going to
have a prompt Vector then concatenate
The Prompt Vector with a noise patch
then once you do so you're going to run
a model on top of it to den know it over
a series of
steps until you end up with with a
particular let's say model and then
you're going to have another decoder
that's going
to that's going
to um turn the final turn the the low
resolution image patch into a high
resolution image
patch and how you do this is that you
install a you can install a KV package
and then from kv. Models this a module
you need to import this class called
stable defici you can create a variable
here called call model and then
instantiate the stable defition class
or's say create an object then it has it
has this two variables you can pass the
the size of the image that you want to
have in this case 512 by 512 to and
then um you can def another variable
called images then this model has a has
a has a method called text to text to
text to image where now you can be able
to pass this this this variables
here Define The Prompt I did just play
with with the text that you want Define
The Prompt how many images do you want
to generate once let's say four them um
how many number steps you want to take
is it 25 is it 50 is it 100 the number
of steps you take decides how clear the
image you're going to have eventually
then also how random would you want the
image to be okay so probably could just
show you some code uh let me end the
show here and just show you some
code
okay I think I have like 9 minutes
remaining so I'll just walk very
fast okay
all right I believe you can see my
screen
so I left something training here it's
s okay did it finish no it didn't okay
anyway all right
so let me just share
this so this one I'm just going to talk
um
a little bit
about yeah about having how how to use U
how to use K 3 so you could install K 3
I think it just released recently like
some two three weeks
ago of course you're going to define the
backend you want to use is it Jack is it
P Touch by saying touch or tens Flow by
adding tens flow here so you could
change
this depending on what you you want to
use and then after that you could decide
to get a let's say a data set somewhere
in this case I may want to use fashion M
data set or you may even want to use
like a custom data set but I realize
that if you're using a custom data set
then you you it means that you're going
to Define you're going to Define your
own data
loader that you're using so in this case
I've been able to Define like a fashion
I've been able to import fashion M from
data set and
then I can decide to explore the data
just see what I have in that data what
are what's the shape um in that data can
I be able to visualize it and see what I
have in it uh what are the classes in
them the class names so I'm just
displaying like 10 random 10 random
images with their labels and you can see
what I'm having
here then of course for me to do
training I can do some processing on the
image I
can do some normalization maybe just
rescale it
[Music]
from from 255
05 to 0 to one and of course we usually
do this this rescaling to help in Faster
convergence then um I also do I can also
add some extra dimensions on the photo
and then at the end of it I can now go
ahead and build my
model and of course the different ways
to build a model you can do you can use
a sequential API use a functional API
and even write your own um you can do
model sub classing or layer sub
classing let me just say model sub
classing so once I have this one here I
want to use the functional API I know
this one is
um I'm going to use functional in this
case so in this particular point I have
uh of course from k. modules from Models
module I'm going to import this class
model then from layers you of course now
you know what a layer is I talked about
it in our slides I want to import all
these ones here and then once I have uh
the input the dce two and all the one
then I'm going
to I'm going to create my model this
functional model I have an input Define
the shape of my model of course the 28
by 28 and it's a gray scale image so you
have one here if it could have been
let's say a colored image you had three
here then here I'm going to have my
convolution my convolution
layer I Define the size uh of of the of
the of the
layer of the filter
sorry so I have 32 filters this is the
size of the filter and then I also have
an activation function here and then I'm
pointing the input to to this
convolution layer then I also have Max
pulling layer here that's going to
ensure that
uh it's going to center it's going to
Center
um the the pulling layer on maybe some
particular pixels uh with with a a size
of 2 by two and then extract the maximum
value from it I think this is stride
this is a stride for
it then I'm going to do both convolution
and Max ping convolution and Max ping
then at some point I'm going to okay
this just a way to do functional API uh
which I just want to focus on K 3 so I
can do like model
summary um then add my optimizers can
add model checkpoint and that is
stopping here
uh model checkpoint will help me to save
the to save the best model maybe at at a
particular point then stopping can
ensure that maybe after three if my my
model the valos is not reducing maybe
after three after three times it can it
can stop the
training so you can do that you can even
go ahead and write let's say cross
functional framework remember in all
these ones we are not using tensor FL
anywhere we just have a caras and a jack
back
end which you can also switch this one
from Jack back end to torch to T or or
even
touch
okay then you can also go ahead and have
your own custom layers Define them
remember what a layer is you have a you
have a state and then you have a a
forward a forward
propagation so you'll Define your state
here that's the weight in the basses you
can find ways to to initialize them and
then you can also Define your for
propagation at this particular point but
remember in this propagation we want to
use something called car. ops meaning
that you can create a back diagnostic
layer with car Ops so you don't
necessarily just have to use tens of FL
here you can be able to use so when you
have K Ops you can use tensorflow or
Jack P and it will still just work uh on
its own or automatically you can also go
ahead and and uh sub class model then
use the
men in your in your model that your
subass model that you're creating and
then at the end of it you can be able to
load some data and then do some training
on it so that that that one is with K 3
and uh how you can be able to run a jack
back end on it and how you can use
things like caras Ops with it